everybody welcome to team cow Monday man
welcome everyone welcome we're back from
Korea it was a crazy trip I've got an
amazing hat on that says Aaron and
Korean right there by the team Coco
Korean fan club right there you can see
that's this little sticker they made we
had an amazing time in Korea
life-changing beautiful incredible trip
we went with Steven Yeun and walking
dead and yeah I mean it was absolutely
unbelievable we had a great time I can't
wait for you guys to see the episode
it's gonna be absolutely spectacular if
you haven't seen the team cocoa
Instagram get on there
Conan took a a truckload full of selfies
while we were there we had an absolutely
amazing time hey angel Gemma's Robin
captain unit Otto Shrek how's it going
how's it going but yes yes run of rental
lol good to see you
but yeah Korean what criolla is
absolutely incredible yeah yeah we don't
know when they chose Canary but it's
coming at coming soon we did get just
inside North Korea which was interesting
I went to the DMZ and yeah yeah it was
it was very interesting we had a it was
that was a very sobering experience we
also went to a monastery up in the
mountains a temple and it did some stuff
with with monks up there which is
gorgeous it was like out of a movie and
Steven took us to some nice restaurants
it was really fun
yeah we had a really really good time
and indeed the I don't know if you guys
have seen photos or video but reception
at the airport thank you so much for
that you guys that was another world the
Conan was completely overwhelmed and so
highlights life highlight he was calling
it so it's fantastic so hello
Gemini what's up Oh Croatia in the house
Croatia in the house Brian Williams
alright I've said your name right whoops
there you go guys
they were playing Firewatch on Steam and
we just started playing games on Steam
and this is the greatest thing is
there's a lot of really cool new games
that we can play that are different than
your normal games that are different
than your normal shoot-'em-ups so oops
wait I should have done that so we're
going to stuff we went we went and
visited a temple Conan learned how to
meditate which is interesting it was it
was beauty that's that's why you gotta
watch this it's fantastic
and yes and we had a great time and it
was really fun the game the the the
monks were extremely cool yeah exactly
Luiz Jose there's your shoutout what up
Diego from Mexico Caspar thank you very
much you're awesome I appreciate that
for the Philippines we got Israel in the
house net is the guy following us as Jon
Snow I don't know what that means
Boulder Colorado 1975 yes my shirt today
I'm naked underneath my clothes guys
we're all naked underneath our clothes
think about it who you see Julia already
I like this game by the way I didn't I
played a little bit of this before we
started I made Beth not watch so she's
gonna start crying it's great she's
about your age late 20s laughing with
well-dressed professors and grad
students from nearby collared University
Boulder you Henri are out drinking with
your pals you approach you're drunk now
what should we say so what's your you
know major or you you're pretty now I
normally go with you're pretty but I say
it like this well we could go you're
pretty let's do it be ready for
disappointments as Alex you're pretty
she says coolly you are not your future
hangover that's true what you reply
confused so much is buy you a
cheeseburger she says she Flags down a
waiter and one week later you're Julia's
boyfriend oh my god if only game over
came here that was a fun game that's
right
how come after I got skinnier I got
worse at gaming
well because I'm just in general in my
life I'm getting oh we got a cool
backpack there you go we're in some kind
of an elevator I feel like things are
only gonna go downhill from here I feel
like we're at our we're in a parking
garage here this is a cool truck we got
this is great square up little boy Bob
Tim what's going on unrealistic
you date for over a year she drives you
absolutely nuts it's great oh man this
game apparel ated no we're playing a
fantasy game guys you move in you share
an apartment near the school the view of
the mountains you to drink beers out on
the deck you drink beer just about
anywhere life is good and life is good
doesn't make for a good game doesn't
it'll lose that pack hey Finn you K hey
Tam trainer what's up hey some braised I
should get a steam controller Oh
interesting
oh you know what I will get a steam
controller Julie wants to get a dog I
love dogs
yet you are bland dating exactly exactly
hey angry blimp sorry there's a scruffy
underside angry blimp listen we got to
take our time with life friend slow down
you know there's a scruffy undersized
beagle Julius and love she wants to
bring over to class
there's also intimidating magenta light
German Shepherd nothing bad could happen
Julie all walking this dog is badass you
pick up the day I'm more of a beagle fan
yeah buckets a great name for a dog I'm
going bucket going bucket hey Lebanon
what's up
let's see now there's a dog this games
gonna turn into John wick oh man what if
the skin friends doing what gets a good
dog and a week later you totally
forgotten about the other one Julia
loves him you love him too is the other
dog gonna come back and kill us 1979 you
talked out on the deck it's summer 9:30
and the heat still radiates off the high
desert what do you think about kids
uh-oh
this game is all just about raising a
family kids they're not very smart or
good at much I'm saying yeah a couple
idiots what do you think that'd be
pretty good
I think we go full in right yeah we're
going all-in that'd be pretty good we're
going all-in yes and get over here
buckets this Tamra is calm and that race
you probably get married yeah I'd like
that oh this is great
kids are gonna be screwed up enough oh
man this is we're just setting ourselves
up for terrible disappointment all right
looks like the Slenderman truck yeah
exactly this looks like the truck how we
become Slenderman well that's what I
feel like we should walk over not forget
to check in there's bears no fires their
filter is not recommended for
inexperienced hikers ooh
this looks dangerous all right
all right so hombres I'm gonna we're
gonna get a steam controller for sure I
might actually buy a steam box should I
buy a steam console I hear good things
about it
oh no oh 1980 things are not going well
first of all it's 1980 so fashion is
terrible she walked in after you'd gone
to bed she's not quite drunk but she's
been having a fun time oh did we give
her the cold shoulder or be a grass
aggressive her passive-aggressive what
do you guys think aggressive or passive
aggressive steam console hell no people
are saying Wow interesting we getting
not passive angry blimps is passive ross
shuman passive aggressive all right
pretty passive aggressive crowd we're
going passive aggressive give her the
cold shoulder you don't touch each other
all night next thing you feel guilty for
being so angry and asked her about her
evening she says it was great you hold
on to a tiny pillow recently this game
is pretty realistic
yeah Julie still likes to draw she draws
plants from her research she draws
little places you go she draws you you
pose and flex like he-man I like the
Victoria Secret model yeah we frolic
Lagoon
yeah love this game whoa mmm what's
happening here
[Music]
I feel like we're gonna find Julia's
dead body here mmm dangerously two forks
eight more miles spacebar to climb over
what's space barn yeah oh there we go
look at that Sun during the summers you
and Julia enjoy walking bucket at night
game to pretty highs enfilade says whoa
Johnny a mug you know this is life man
you get ups and downs bunky gets kicked
ooh
do we beat his goddamn face in I think
you have to man this game is basically a
park ranger similar but Brittany's
goddamn facing yeah hmm then on we walk
by the river all right notice me and
boss you've been noticed uh plans that
kids get waylaid by work always work
Julie gets offered a job at Yale yells
in Connecticut 2,000 miles away it's a
great job she wants to move wait what
why is there not a thing of you move
well apparently we're a dick in this
game well what I want her to take the
job but I don't want to have to make her
commute both of those are awful these
are bad options these are bad options
what do we do yeah
agree if she commutes commute I guess
yeah this choice sucks I agree why are
we a dick Hendricks eating eggs it's so
important that you can't do it remotely
yeah this choice sucks commute commute
commute okay fine yeah Henry's a dick
fine we're saying - Yahoo
oh she said it'll be hard but she'll do
it if you won't move all right
I mean look as long as she's happy but
she's not cuz we should have just moved
with her this is stupid
oh oh no oh oh she's having she's yeah
she's going a little crazy oh now we've
got to talk to somebody but I'd give me
all we're also gonna make macaroni but
oh no oh no early onset dementia why are
we keeping a secret also a bad idea this
is kind of freaking me out a little bit
here
pick up the journal my hands are weirdly
meaty what is this oh that's me you're
very pretty
oh that's me yeah buckets getting older
Julie comments is kind of nice cuz he
gets in less trouble around the house oh
man this is gonna be this game is
hardcore oh no this is horrible guys I'm
sorry to start off the week on such a
bummer of a game there's a shambles oh
no oh no she's devastated
ah I want permanent medical leave it's
probably the commuting we should have
just moved there whoa
Oh God oh my god this is intense draw me
like your french girls is crazy sunshine
tell her family she's from Australia
that's interesting
she gets worse ah this is making me
depressed yeah Jeff Stephen I'm not
prepared for this
you spend your days following Julie
around the house you count the sexes
doing the two weekly visitors me another
nurse Oh No to remove her into full care
facility I feel like I don't want to
move her into a full care facility but
on the other hand I know if we picked it
by the by yourself thing is gonna tear
you apart yeah and it's also something
Bad's gonna happen all right I'm sorry
Kinghorn popgoes this game on a Monday
the feels my gosh I'm sorry I didn't
know I thought this game was gonna be
like fire and crazy and instead it's
entries in the comments oh my god this
is rough Gingras is saying oh man this
is yeah this is gnarly this game is too
complicated sin Landy someone just
someone that on YouTube just goes
Deadpool Goodwin we go and now we're all
bummed out this freakish coin he's got a
dog and then ever since then oh look at
this these are our peaceful escapes I
think her family agrees your decision
you find a fantastic place in Boulder
mover there you see her every day
oh no then every other day I'm not alike
this at all no pulling away from the
friends I would to honestly
man Chili's sister Susan moved to be a
man if we hook up with Susan I'm
quitting this game I'm quitting this
game I'm not gonna do that bucket dies
ah damn it this is like the beginning of
up this game is oh no oh no oh
Julia it's breaking my heart the tears
of chilly fall goes the tears of life
equal the best guest for Monday melee we
take the job okay is it in Boulder I
mean the irony [ __ ] it
wait a brightening my Monday sorry
seasons are a classy woman Far Cry
primal nope although I believe tomorrow
I think we're doing a new gamer we're
gonna have any game around the show I
believe tomorrow night all right here we
are I mean nothing could be scarier than
true life which is what this game
supposedly is so far
why I mean
this is our job interesting Sombra says
this game's called fire watch because it
makes your heart burn up in flames
subtitle requests yet yep alright you
know what why don't you chill out for a
second alright
Delilah guaranteed by the way right now
I'm making a prediction
Delilah does not exist Delilah is in our
head I'm making a prediction I've seen
this before
you know Delilah we're going a little
crazy please
[Music]
I'm saying right now Dalila is actually
julia old julia in our head that's what
I think that's that's my prediction guys
where is she why how can she see us at
our desk also we can't hear the game
someone saying subtitles I put the
subtitles on five dollars Delilah is a
tree so I was she's an aunt ooh yeah
charger we got what is that it's I feel
like we either go up on that or down on
that and up on that because that take a
picture what are you so up on you're
going we echo so no gameplay audio off
if you turn that up well I was gonna go
I'll turn this down oh I see I see I see
yeah so I'll turn this up and that down
hold on one sec guys someone said this
would be a badass job if you had steady
internet there mister
where'd you say a thing with a loud
round Blart Oh a map little art what did
she say
can you guys hear okay I also hold on
one sec let me turn voice up
how's that everyone which weighs less
which way is west
what's n how Jesus west right no but Wes
yeah hold on
where now I don't see any fireworks
chill out
I don't see me forward
oh I see him now all right let's go do I
bring my pack
no we don't oh I bring it oh I can
handle it Delilah / Julia yeah
what are we gonna say he wrote to get
down the [ __ ] alright Oh
[Applause]
bucket ghosts is lighting fireworks
where am I going here uh so I want to go
straight Oh No
left I think this is the way right
that's what she said set him straight to
the lake West am I going the right way
do we think cash 3:06 cash money cash
cash money yeah it would be a terrible
fire watchman at West it is am I going
the right way
Oh nope I'm not going the right way at
all I got to go right yeah 306 is there
I gotta go north I think so North is
this way all right all right
North it is we're heading back towards
where we just were
okay running over things I'll write this
up constantly check map travel is quick
people are saying so begin the story of
the village oh yeah alright yeah I know
exactly all right wait
yeah that you know what the map is not
that big because we're traveling pretty
fast here I think yeah
are we working long pants do you think
cuz I feel like there's oh I just saw
some ankle yeah that's bad because they
like we're gonna get some like bad like
you know ticks carry Lyme disease that's
all I'm saying I think this is cashbox
306 yeah we did it thanks Delilah yeah
is there a cure for dementia in here
that really helped me out my wife I
don't easy buddy yeah we go boom nailed
it oh okay thank God okay so you hungry
I'm gonna deal with them already what
does the note say
cue to read note which one is the okay
Ron hey man I couldn't take it so our
locked up is look out what oh the guy
went crazy shiny yeah shining in the
woods all those bars you liked hiking
the park but let's get [ __ ] when I
back day alright she we ask you people
lose their [ __ ] out here seems a little
terse wait what was it always Jack
Torrance in the shining right it wasn't
Henry alright copy information
when they murder wrong I'm not gonna
hurt you Indy I'm just gonna bash your
brains in all right the [ __ ] scheme
loves the F word gluten tag Oh guten tag
sorry I'm sorry Albert I thought you
said glutes something about gluten
gutentag to yourself tag friend alright
do I just need to go find them now
they're not on the map though I mean
they were shooting soon enough in the
sky
are they West I guess we can hear them
it feels like we're getting closer
doesn't it
Oh what was that seemed like a good time
of day for fireworks
she's definitely a ghost definitely a
ghost I'm saying it now when you're dead
after your crazy and dead with an axe
the view that debt viewed oh alright
there we go
they're over there let's go you be
Delilah is like the Lloyd yeah no she's
definitely Lloyd are you think yeah no I
think it's a thing of back in the 20s
when you are alive the acting this game
is amazing it does who are the people in
this game alright well let's go down do
detest the rope bro ain't got no time
from Mad Men okay over it's summer oh
yeah oh it's crane it's Harry crane yeah
to show a picture show that hold that up
the thing Harry crane this is the guy
who's whose voice this is who we are
that guy format you can't see the TV guy
the guy from that man yeah that's what I
kappa yes it's that guy yeah it's a TV
guy Harry crane yes Liam Liam Templeton
you're right from a YouTube
Oh No
ooh that was bad maybe if you had long
pants on Oscar the Grouch its seltzer I
like taking salt Oh No weirdly now look
it looks later I think we blacked out
slash slash time there's no such thing
as time in purgatory wait maybe we're
already dead I think I can't I'm a ghost
yeah that's exactly what it is
we've are we're already dead this is my
this new prediction we're already dead
and this is like purgatory slash heaven
and we're meeting Julia yeah at the end
we're gonna meet Julia in heaven or hell
Firewatch 127 hours Team Coco addiction
I love it Ross I don't need to report
everything man we're out in the woods
stop predicting so skip the snuggler
it's like shutter eyelid I agree Cathy
beer can no it's okay the rocks broke
his fall yeah I'm just like reporting
everything man where these other ghosts
are hanging out
yeah Gingras this this game is
everybody's gone to the Firewatch
basically Firewatch like hell seagull
basses that's too cliche my prediction
is they're all alive and live happily
ever after you know what that actually
the biggest plot device that actually
would be a great flaw choice that
they're just a lot it's just a game it's
the same stuff that I used to drink in
my when I was alive
interesting that says my hat says my
name in Korean the fans gave it to me we
were over in Korea it's my favorite hat
drink the whiskey's his angry blip I
don't think you can can you good one our
dicks too close yeah let's uh I have an
idea let's take their clothes this is
getting pervy this people are all
definitely dead guaranteed this is
everybody's dead guaranteed what is
going on
Peppa Peppa Peppa Peppa penny purple
panties yeah good question
I feel like probably teens they're drunk
where's the dance
dance you know naked ladies what do we
say quit the fireworks [ __ ] or else yeah
what would a professionals say I know
you're lighting fire ops yeah yeah
basically oh my god
all right bust their ass get out the
knife kill him they deserve to die I
[Music]
didn't touch your stuff oh my god
respect my authority women pop up up up
up up panties this is definitely him
like dealing with some of this stuff huh
and heard the Zodiac killer Chewbacca's
that's it
whoa where do they go whoa they just
disappeared
it's done it's done I killed them
maybe I killed him wait they just
disappeared man like that spooky is
right you're right there ghosts is right
he said because he's still holding the
can this is what you should I they went
behind the rock somebody said hmm and we
find the rock back to life
they got me encouraged I'm not gonna
throw my radio at them okay yeah Orion
Penndel says they walk back behind the
big rock all right fair enough
see now the music is getting creepy to
me and it keeps playing Camp Crystal
Lake I feel you kept yeah exactly killed
by sweet jams all right let's go back
it's like when I try to buy jeans really
quickly that gives the song at the store
is just horrible exactly I get out of
there just got to buy and buy and run
now it's like weirdly quiet this game is
creepy it's all like in the golden hour
oh keep the smuggler I'm from the town
of Crystal Lake the lake is actually
quite pleasant I can't take the boombox
crazy sunshine
I'm not going drop
no I can figure it out myself see here
we're just a wandering made that goes
yeah let's see oh wait a second you know
what I think we can be like true
Widowmaker no wait
can we climb up the thing or do I need
to go around what do you think
interesting well let's go I mean I guess
let's go back the way we came although I
feel like we're not gonna be able to get
up the Widowmaker because the water the
rope broke right so let's go down to how
I'm gonna get back up there well let's
go back to the Widowmaker
please wearing his hat like a teenager
that's too big goes comes out Winstar a
big ghost comes out would be lame
I don't believe you how can a ghost come
out there are no ghosts in this game
except for us go back and go I'll go
back to Lincoln go around alright keep
the snuggler can be believed there's an
exploit with multiplayer games that on
the source engine blah blah I don't know
what he's talking though it'd be a good
idea called the law oh yeah that's true
perfect right where the monster is go
towards the monster why do I hate asking
for directions ok Touche I know I'm in
the bushes
[Music]
Oh God like life before Bluetooth
speakers when you couldn't play and he
said oh whoa Bree it's weird how the
light changes very quickly it freaks me
out
spoiler dalila's conan's is braum
lesbian seen coming i don't think so
hey thanks lazy lazy one this hat was
given to me by a fan at Korea it says my
name on it
it's awesome we did awesome time in
Korea it's really really fun
Connor Barrett we are not too far into
this game we've only been playing we've
been playing for about 45 minutes it's
before you five minutes Wow time flies
you're having fun and pretending you're
ghost in limbo it's a nice little this
is a beautiful game acting is awesome i
I'm your I'm your wife another form of
my head there was no radio I know
there's gonna be no radio Marcus gay
your test works yeah she can hear it too
and we're in and we're in a flood plain
great I'll try
that's right ha yeah I'm not sure I got
a lot of choice in getting struck down
let's look in here this one wait oh I
can't respond to everything man she's so
chatty
what is she running from besides the
fact she's a dead ghost
copy that map information alien
isolation taught me anything let's look
at the map what's in here
something stands on
whatever whatever Thank You Albert I do
this game was so underwhelming says no
hate I like it so far
I like the dialogues great you guys are
crazy on the naked milk man
the point of this game is this is one of
those games where like everybody's gone
to the rapture or or gone home where
you're kind of it's a story it's a movie
and a game so we're kind of trying to
figure out why we're here what's going
on
Oh flashlight this is what we need yep
ah perfect I have to toggle the
flashlight F would be what's F oh yeah
let's go in this cave F what's F that's
our thing that's our thing that's our
thing that's nothing what's the what's F
Oh F okay
what's in the cave what's in the box
what's in the box oh so mr. language
that's how I open doors boom
first is this gonna be the descent she's
calling me Hank we're getting to be
better friends
that's what Julia called me I noticed
the wedding rings very prominent on my
finger keep hitting it until dawn Ross
says until dawn taught me when D goes
live there until dawn was freaky I gotta
say it's getting dark they're gonna be
windigos finally if you guys haven't
played until dawn it's great
PS we 2008 whoa Korea was amazing he's
really jerking it very funny all right
well done well done Delilah or Julia
should I say well I can't go up this way
just like blocked off or something guy
clamp here no not digging the darkness
that much it's a little scary you know
what I wonder if that was me from the
future you know it comes back around
like Prince of Persia Thank You ESCO
beets we appreciate appreciate you
saying that
Oh Matt on YouTube we're gonna be
playing for about and we're played till
1:30 so about another 40 minutes or so
and it could be 40 minutes of me just
walking up and down this path
guys you know my position on flashlights
and games and that is I don't like using
flashlights and games because it makes
me feel like I'm a target and it doesn't
matter if it's a thing oh geez and it
doesn't matter if it's a thing where the
enemies can't see the flashlight
psychologically it throws me off so I
prefer to walk around in the darkness
we're just gonna keep going up however
if it does get too dark to see I will
use a flashlight use the flashlight
leave I'll AC no I'm not gonna use the
flash that we just talked about this
Coke aids treating me well what did
that's a great name but I won't say
let's climb up here
[Music]
but Donnie Rao whose errand blared
I've been asking myself that for years
nobody knows nobody knows I'm a nobody
real with fire all right with fire you
can't do that outlast you have to have
light to get out of you in one room
that's true that's true
good point some games you have to use it
but if I if you dude careful bro now
we're back we're back to our station is
this our station this is extremely
creepy forest burns is funny that's a
good joke good joke Wat twist you are
the radio
[Music]
Frodo flagons yes I got to show off my
guns every stream I worked hard for
these guns they've gotta be showed off
it's not pick up an old baseball bats in
an outhouse gross gotta wash our hands
man
show the baseball outside so it goes can
throw it at us
can use this or with the deal here
actually like yes I pee wherever I want
cuz I'm a ghost
this is tell Mouse yes I'm very tired
from Korea I have a set it's a 17 hour
time difference so my body is extremely
tired but you know what for you guys the
green let's play through that's right
I'm here we're playing Monday melee this
game you're just joining us this game is
called fire watch what my type writers
outside could be music playing somebody
up there unhappy about this dude I'm
unhappy about this I don't like this at
all I don't like this at all by the way
hmm these drums are freaking me out man
there's somebody up here if you're just
joining us for playing this game called
fire watch and it's starting to get a
little freaky our place has been trashed
watch any fire yet
yeah our place has been trashed man what
look at this
can I still report vandalism man this
sucks I'm starting a little nervous
about this game didn't take the fire
finder
like there's glory what is this damn
messy ghosts uh yes Andrew
yes cry Andrew Crowley maybe when you
blacked out you trashed it yourself yeah
I think it's the kind of can you do the
language brownie Veronica thinks it's
for late kids Ville says there's a
shotgun in the outhouse and there's
zombies I know if I believe them other
zombies out here I love you too
PewDiePie clueless gamers coming I think
tomorrow night just tell me where to
find a gun you mean the popemobile
there's no gun totally late kids
it's the chupacabra maybe it was her
yeah maybe it's her yeah
day two oh man this game is getting a
little creepy you guys there are no dead
waffle foot there's no zombies or
shotgun woo look at this little chilly
out here
alright
wake up it's day 2 in your purgatory yep
always cut off in a horror movie
can I go fix it Eric Pollock well here's
the space tin it's 1986 Willy
Hank she's Hank
it's Henry no I don't like Hank
no thanks rhymes with Hanks I have to
say though if you're Tom Hanks it's
pretty cool at the end of every letter
you could just write T Hanks it would
also be thanks yeah so it kind of saves
you you know that that's probably the
best thing about being Tom Hanks don't
tread on me Matt it's a mixed message
all right so where we going today let's
see we're going through where do we need
to go survey communications I north of
the canyon no matter this is the year
the Challenger Space Shuttle mm-hmm
maybe we're an astronaut communication
lines north of the canyon there's
thunder Canyon I mean ok I don't really
know where the communication line there
is but I guess we'll find it
ah lesbian as know this is not the game
where you where you fight the King Koopa
you're thinking of Super Mario Brothers
okay
the tee-hanks II was a stupid thing I've
ever heard
bones this must be your first time on
Monday melee because I've said way
stupider things way stupider hey what's
up who's boss thank you for joining us
today guys were playing fire watch on
steam don't see like that was the like
that the two women were bathing at
before
anyway let's check our map let's see
here okay we want to go up are we going
up oh my god I keep looking at the wrong
thing so yeah this is right right cuz we
don't want to go I'm gonna go the
opposite way Jonesy Lake cuz this is the
right way north of the canyon
she said north bear ski you're right
that's where we're going north all right
I should look at my frickin compass by
the way I haven't I've never really gone
camping out in LA and I know I should
and this is why because I'm terrible at
all kinds of outdoor things night killer
10 I am NOT Conan O'Brien your eyes are
very good miss I don't like mist mist is
bad
am i reporting everything all right fine
let's report the myth report the mist
how can I do it oh I'm cold
what's life like yeah she wouldn't know
she's dead
yeah you would know it's dead I'm gonna
talk about Juliet in my life
when I was alive I did where she's
dementia thanks for making fun of it can
I go into the water
yeah
zombies yep yep she's not being truthful
with us maybe she's like maybe this is a
sign about Julia I think this is I'm now
thinking that we've been hypnotized and
this is our therapist helping us with
our problems we're being honest
honesty's the best policy guys I gotta
go do a thing I have to go write up a
report on my new patient Henry am I
going the right way here you're going
north see I think keeping things from
her is not a good idea
you're just go north right not south I'm
going north correct
turbo today we're headed north
the guy falling oh yeah okay perfect
better ending perfect I think people are
putting spoilers on the chat just fine
because I don't believe anybody anything
says in your line is that they're all
lies I'll be back at our Tower how are
we back in our Tower uh
we're back at our Tower get back here
North the wrong way all right we're
going here we go we're going north
I thought that was I thought something
creepy pretty lame dude guy following
you is the Weiler self hey dad dad it's
like seeing you maybe
the thing is here's the thing are we go
star is this a therapy exercise you know
what I'm saying
Dalila clear okay here's the things we
know Dalila clearly isn't who she says
she is I think it Delilah is a part of
our personality that we're having
trouble dealing with and none of this is
actually truthful missing
all right we're going the right way
right are we going the right way
yes is good
oh yeah we're kind of going towards the
cave where we were before
[Applause]
vodka D no no we're playing this on
Steam today we are playing fire watch on
steam and it is pretty fun so far I got
to say it's very interesting game it's
making us sad in our hearts yeah I think
you know and confused but in a fun way
there's a lot of missed I'm I'm
wondering if there's windigos to be had
we're going back to this cave which is
definitely scary man F this cave dude
not into caves man we got missed in the
cave Oh danger how are we doing all
right
still headed north hey Lance Gabriel tan
hello yourself
that's right if you know how this game
ends don't say it in the chat don't be a
dick
don't spoil things for people that's not
cool maybe some people won't play this
game you know caves where iron man was
born Ivanka Trump you're exactly right
iron man was kind of born in a cave he
made that armor right Tony Stark
prop hat I know I hate you
blows meow bleh we're in a cave Barna
cave is still in an emotional cave here
we go
this guy's like the number one Korean
celeb that's you mm-hmm that's Conan
known as an evergreen slab I'm like
let's report the utility pole you're
lying
following okay [ __ ] because that's where
I've set my trap ps3 tip 92 this seems
like a mystery for the mystery gang guys
let's start a mystery gang we solve
mysteries or we make mysteries Beartooth
me and stuff in the woods is all has
cool names like lizard rock and bear
tooth and you wolf Fang you know like
everything is so cool the city it's like
Oh Main Street yeah why don't they named
it like wolf Fang Avenue you know you're
lying to Lyle I know you are yeah looks
like some players
let's just light some fires they'll send
someone out immediately
you know Blue's Clues I spied tert who
certainly duck I haven't seen the new
x-files episodes but you're the great
you have tonight oh my god I need to
watch them right should I watch them all
right do they live up to your
expectations that's a bummer although
Camille's in it yeah he's a he's another
like the best one the can't get down
there how do I get across that is bush
Gillian Anderson is still very hot she's
super hot and in Hannibal I'm sure she's
on the x-files she only gets Third Age
new x-files are great sis ps3
definitely watch him I will king Gris
thank you I go in the right way here yep
yeah this is the new Kanye West video
game he did it while he announced that
he's doing when he kind of showed some
parts of it here's the thing it's all
you play his mother and she's trying to
get to heaven so you know it's not
something I really want to touch with
you know I mean I think it's great he
did that I think that's very nice and
honorable of him to do that
it seems like because if you don't do it
then she doesn't get into heaven
next seems like a bad thing poor turtle
hey buddy Shelley Duvall from the
shining shining shining reference this
is definitely like The Shining you guys
what she said she said I love The
Shining
oh my god it's totally shining Oh No
I through Shelley Duvall down
about time I ran into animals as a token
and a bow copy information always chilly
falls this sounds like a good game for
Monday melee
well the done too wet her name is Don de
I think time to West game isn't done I
only saw footage of it online pinecone -
EEE - pinecone can you eat it can you
report pinecone please
what's this board Oh
six feet down under what is this
oh the novel okay do anything with it
throwing things around
I mean should I put this back in the box
past the snake this game is Firewatch on
Steam so far it's very creepy we're
learning a lot about what's going on
here we've got a turtle we're gonna take
with us that's right Oh Shelly you're so
cute is there any option to put this oa
Dopp t' hold e which ones e woody B this
one
Oh adopted adopted Shelly right so he's
down the ground I'd opt-in Shelly Rio
here claw a compass more north let's go
look there's a note in the cache turbo
says I miss the note let's go back and
read it thank you guys for helping us
out by the way I your help is always
appreciated if it's real help and not
fake and not spoilers like a dick so no
oh this is no hey Dave hey Oh
gonna track you down been looking for
you all day for you to be I don't know
the candy helping those grad students
but I guess not oh the grad students are
probably in the lake now I could really
help anyway we're coworkers you know
amigos profession allies need someone to
throw back a case with a go
time-traveling rods your guy yeah I'm
back I got it I got it
huh so it's like two guys hello Eleanor
Haseman tonight I dine on turtle stew no
no no jelly we're not doing it what's
happening here we go up it I don't see
another place we can go up here unless
it's this
follow the powerlines and see follow the
powerlines okay where are the power
lines
Oh up over there
I can't kill this way though Brenda jump
here's thank you
loving this hat it says Erin it's
embroidered it was given to me by Korean
fan I appreciate it
hey mags our entertainment
greetings to Denmark hello thank you for
joining us so how do I get over there is
the quite is my question am I missing a
path oh boy oh here we go or you could
float up the hill I'll go see what the
damage is why wow it's down we know the
damage what I'm going to say like oh
it's been freight you know what I bet
it's been cut yeah there's a knife next
to it with a sign this is you and then
like a how do I get up there hello bash
gangee hello to India what time is it in
India right now how do I get the F up
there maybe this way what do you think I
gotta go back down do you think it's
back down and up that's what it feels
like right where you came from take a
left and follow the path this other
right got it thank you I appreciate it
this is where it gets a little more
interesting they say Oh
conquer moves I don't know if I'll ever
do a Bob Ross paying thing but I love
that twitch did that that was super cool
hey Nev it's 5 a.m. in Malaysia Wow 2:46
a.m. in India geez
thank you for watching us guys that's
very nice of you god damn kids
language please it's you Delilah
don't give me that [ __ ] I know it's you
ah a grow Berlin poop is Cohn in such an
ass in real life garden is hilarious in
real life for sure he's the man he's
super nice he's just a really nice great
guy and he is as goofy in real life but
it's more it's darker and flinging it
like it's more like real humor rather
than just like the end of the wire bunch
of dalila's beer cans whoa what is this
whoa hey Korea it's 6:00 a.m. in Korea
oh my goodness thank you guys
panties can I get closer into that how
do I get closer to the panties guys how
can I get closer to those panties I mean
in my real life
how do I report I like to report panties
please turn pointer into the why Oh into
the where inspect don't ever grab the
wire idiot I'm already dead so I guess
that doesn't matter
ooh hi did not expect that
[Music]
hey so the liar is definitely down out
here I just found
there's also poop up up up up up panties
yep yep
by someone named Delilah there's not
people die cuz I'd kill them kill them
she's a killer she's a killer
Delilah this is not professional
especially from a ghost dude I'm telling
you this like The Shining PS 3 tip 92 I
have plate layers of fear and it's
horrifying it's very good I played it on
my own channel twitch.tv slash Aaron
blur any much you probably get an
achievement if you collect all the
panties in the game ready go hey slayer
Darth they're actually Conan's panties
as ESCO beach soccer kids three seven
six seven you're a killer don't listen
yeah maybe
wait maybe we yeah maybe we're a bad guy
that's interesting and this is we're
finding our own stuff like we black out
never were like we wake up we're like oh
it's like a it's a it's like a Fight
Club situation we wake up and all of a
sudden you when we've been sleeping is
when all this [ __ ] goes down I like it
we just can't take it the Julia stuff
has made us crack alright what am I
supposed to uh guys I again the fire
crotch jokes I get it fire watch fire
crotch well done well done but you guys
are masterful comedians hold on
okay where are these goddamn teens let's
go scare the team so scare the team yeah
like a professional wait where we go
where the teens again head back to our
camp and you'll see something like more
beard yeah we'll see just blood
everywhere
all right back to our camp
guys by the way I we don't need spoilers
in this stuff but thank you that uh yet
that it that up all right where am I
going no idea this is exactly how it be
me in real life by the way totally lost
finding teens so many teen yeah me in
real life just finding creepy teens play
a real game like Battlefield how about
no this is a real game battlefield is
fun but so is this how do I get down
free your mind Neil you know there's
other games out there besides games
where you kill each other
there's games like this where you stalk
each other how do I know this is the
right way nope there's games like this
Neil look at this isn't this more fun
than battlefield wandering around in the
woods I like it I like it damn it
I came here to watch them fire what in
the heck is this yeah sorry it's it's
emotional fire you missed the beginning
where we went through a whole thing
where what yeah we've been through the
frickin fire dude emotional fire the
worst kind so sad I bet we killed Julia
I bet we put her out of her misery and
then we freaked out and had to do this
alright I gotta leave a map are we going
here alright so
we want to go south and then to our left
South and then left
[Applause]
go up the hill and take everywhere go up
they land take a left
Oh Oh cuz we can't go back down the
movie no I don't think that's right we
go down and we take a left there should
be a little route down here oh yeah you
know what because I don't know if we can
jump up cuz we're fat I know if we'll be
able to pull ourselves up here see this
is the way we came down we can't we
can't go back that way oh yeah okay you
guys are right thank you
so we go back up and let me take a left
right so we want turn around okay
back up and take a left
miss Sal yes we play a lot of games
every Monday here at noon we play a game
here we go it's this way
I believe nope nope this way back into
the left just like Kennedy's head when
it was shot
this part of the game is driving okay I
can't go that way though we go up and
over and around oh this way
there we go
shady fridge that's right kind of makes
a cameo in my little short film pretty
cool it's out now go see it hey Batman
to zero what's up
pancake laser I love that name by the
way let's see Russian joint says I look
like a big fatty who doesn't vape thank
you I'll take that as a compliment I
think it can only be taken Thank You
Nissel Pereira
we appreciate you loving our stream I
appreciate you coming here we go long
drop down we're gonna pass out again and
then murder the teens do I want to go to
the drop or jonesy lake Justin Justin
ass this is fire watch on steam let's go
down here we don't need to go to the job
Oh chilly follow the name the short film
is called how to lose weight in four
easy steps
Beth will throw a link in there it's how
to lose weight four easy steps calm very
easy to remember
and yes see if you could spot mr. CEO be
do I have a rope my rope broke come on I
could climb down this uh Don grinder No
Conan doesn't play any online poker I
don't think Conan's a big gambler
actually more of a drinker maybe I
should have gone to that drop find the
teens of trying that's my life is trying
to find the teens my whole life
oh wait what's this whoa
what's in it a human head back when I
died
woohoo I'd like to pilfered please
that's sweet
hey let's get our fingerprints all over
this backpack of this dead kid Brian
Goodwin thanks Brian
since you're dead well that's good
that's not incriminating that's not a
criminal in decent condition - there's
enough rope here that I could just leave
them hooked up I think one of those
cardboard single-use cameras but it's
not gonna come out cuz I'm a ghost
I hate cameras and games I hate when you
have to take pictures and sucks you know
I killed him he's dead he's dead he's
dead guaranteed he's dead next letter is
dead said he's definitely dead dead kid
dead alert
wait Nate children wait Ned's is one of
the guys in the note right thank you
wait Ned Ned was one of the guys Ned I
bet Ned was the guy with a flashlight
looking for his dead son you know I'm
saying the ghost like the balls
where does rocks in purgatory no wait
let's use the disposable camera how do
we do that no oh there we go
Ned rhymes with dead confirmed yeah all
right well I'm not taking any more
photos
hmm all right let's get out of here
I hate cameras and games you have to
take photos of stuff it's boring mags or
I do not play League of Legends but
maybe I should care league of Legends is
great it's your son Ron is the note
yeah skull studs may be weird Ned
Goodwin really in our hearts what is our
name it's not Ned
oh it's Henry that's right it doesn't
just sound like Ned all right good
the plot thickens you guys how do I jump
down damn it you're telling me I can't
get down this simple thing here come on
bro I guess I'm just stuck here maybe
Rob killed net and Brian you're right
rich Richy TV could be how do I get the
Frick down here hello I'd like to jump
down please
why awesome boss gaming we're playing
this on Steam it's not a console or
playing this on Steam oh wait wait
I thought I saw something just pop up
just now oh oh here's a rope hook right
here another rope shady I have played a
little bit of hearthstone I'm not a huge
card game fan but I have played a little
bit Oh Don grinder thank you that's
actually a good tip I don't need to use
the camera it just shows me
it'll show during the credits at the end
of the game thank you that's actually
not a spoiler that's a great tip thank
you because I hate taking photos and
games almost just almost as much as I
hate using a flashlight yeah you mix
Henry and Illuminati Brendan jump you
says it comes out Ned so you are Ned and
your son is dead
I like where your head's at I like we
are head in with this netted oh look at
this a fence
what no trespassing mm-hmm can't go that
way
send Delilah nudes somebody's they
that's hilarious
you can't send him nudes did it was 86
it was before you had to prove you had
there you go yeah yep
did getting developed get it yeah then
you had to get an envelope get some
stamps hmm
what oh she's got Alzheimer's dementia
just like you have cuz you're killing
people she's not is she
thank you she's with her family in
Melbourne Australia she's 43 yeah
language Oh is awesome well the funny
thing it was like devastating idiot no
suggesting put this down devastating
especially for her you can understand
anyway everything she worked for was
taken away
snap the pigeon how about a little
positivity bro yeah I'm sorry to be such
a downer happy to listen and kill for
you
have some fun killing hikers killing
teens been some of the news in to camera
all hand-drawn yeah hand-drawn dudes
yeah you're right
oh that's old school support that know
these guys Ron and Dave they're leaving
notes for each other in the boxes or is
that Ned dead Ned
she's in the nudes too man
super into nudes what does Antoniou
talking about hashtag killing teens
let's not make that a hashtag kept the
snuggler hmm oh don't put that down dude
am i doing here I need to go south which
is this way nope
yes is this way Oh so we do need to go
to the fence port the fence
we're on and canyon equals Conan oh good
one I can't report the fence oh yeah I
smell [ __ ] yeah you know what's up
they keep an outer in what are they
keeping in what do you think they're
keeping it you its head should I just
stop you know what is this she's the
worst
surly duck because hashtag find the
team's is so much better Touche Touche
oh my god stop talking Delilah please
please stop please stop
kept you in the loop thanks for all of
the high quality information Delilah
please you're killing me you can't
remember the lines cut I caught you in a
lie while I ruined your stuff someone
kill people did say burn tree here
excuse me I shot what she's in the
future what is this girl's crazy man hey
flapjack why don't you wait your turn
before I bounce your face off it dumb
who speaks like this miss katene who
said Brian Goodwin was also the name of
a professor and founder of the field of
theoretical biology whoa
sloppy young woman sounds like my types
is good it is actually I stumbled over
and told her she was pretty and that was
it he was drunk that night we died and
the whole Julia thing is fake
flapjacks are good shady fridge you're
right koalas a boyfriend says legacy
sage awesome boss gave me I am enjoying
this game actually I like I like games
that have story telling I think it's
cool
Jack Porter I'm sorry Jordans busy doing
various various duties and
responsibilities right now he was a big
hit he was a big hit I saw a lot of
people wearing Jordan masks is pretty
funny that's amazing it was great
cRIO is super fun I definitely have to
go back at some point what do you think
is gonna happen when we get back to our
station what's gonna be done more stuff
it's gonna be like a scroll it says like
you baseball is gonna be in oh yeah oh
yes josh lopez I think Delilah is evil I
will say of the fire I set because I'm
crazy let's just kill these games really
do that not a one
good lord
this is gotta just be ghosts gods I
think I hate to say it oh there's the
plume of smoke all right we're gonna
find our way to the smoke then we're
gonna call it for today I think I'm in
the woods I'm in the woods I'm in the
woods I'm in the woods I hope I put bug
spray on that's why I have to say a lot
of bugs out here I feel like one right
way am I going back I don't feel like I
was oh I don't feel like I was here
before all right
ten bucks says that's the beer aisle
used to like to drink guaranteed and he
got drunk and like something happened
spero HD my favorite game of 2015 that's
a hard one I played a lot of good games
I really I mean I enjoyed playing
Fallout 4 quite a bit
I've enjoyed I enjoyed until dawn was
really fun
[Applause]
alien isolation has been really great
man lot of number not look lawton lot no
8 I would love to go back to Korea I get
such a good time I cannot wait for you
guys to see the Korea episode it's
really really good you guys are gonna
love it
continue my murdering spree in the city
because I'm actually dead and I can't
take a plane because I've killed her
bags now her sister Susan is straight
but her parents I think they always
thought she could do better
where's the smoke the lights changing
again don't know the thing like dying
keep you away
oh I have the option of cleaning up
those cans look sorry Gingras uh-oh
Brian Goodwin right Mike Mitch Michaels
[ __ ] - Michaels
interesting
oh you can also read it that's cool
perfect a lot of pinecones in here it's
just gonna be like more dead stuff all
right should we dress this summer
there's an area down here that's
learning a lot about you gonna smoke or
should we just end for today I feel like
we're running over time we got meetings
and stuff
although I kind of want to see this
smoke that's gonna happen it's a really
nice harmful down here do those girls
love skinny-dipping I bet they're nearby
oh man what's happening where's the
smoke
[Music]
shouldn't be able to see the smoke
[Music]
well the Wyoming wilderness is the same
as in this game someone is saying that's
awesome it takes a while to give the
smoke smoke
I missed the red jacket where's the red
jacket send me on the tree what tree
it's tough the delay for the stream is
like a minute oh oh back here oh cool
Brian gonna winds jacket guaranteed dead
kids jacket dead kids jacket it says
help I'm dead
aha Baker this is uh this is steam we're
playing on a computer wait should I go
that way through these things Technic
studios how did you like this game wait
now this is oh here we go my sheets
let's report some teens in my pants
[Music]
dangerous hugs gates of beer you know
that could all be one call we don't need
to do three separate calls it could be
like I found some magazines in a case of
beer found my sheets slash you did stomp
out this fire Hey
where's Shelley Duvall that's what I
wanted teen zone already reported it I
reported it whoa it was you Delilah or
crazy Firewatch Delilah's definitely
killed these people
debt or ID either Delilah or me no seven
eight this [ __ ] they're probably dead I
think yeah great idea you're psycho I
hope you're freaking happy we're leaving
and we're going to find the police or
whatever tell about how you creeped us
on Oh destroyed our camps a lot of stuff
Oh still opinions he's gross out my
mental ax murderer Delilah definitely or
we did
what I did what if I was like I did
don't be ridiculous it's you Delilah the
chupacabra what if they're DTF I mean
who can say oh don't forget to make no
[ __ ] day three guys I'll do it for
today's dream thank you for joining us
the game has been fire watch and we
played it on Steam it was fantastic
again thank you so much for watching
thank you to the people of Korea for the
amazing hat and all the incredible
generous hospitality that episode will
be coming very soon I believe we have a
clueless gamer coming up this week
hopefully the pewdiepie and for Jason
O'Malley and Beth Morosky we'll see you
all next week at noon for Monday eyes
you